bonsoir à toutes et à tous
avant toute chose je souhaite et je
voudrais féliciter
anne hidalgo pour son élection je
voulais aussi remercié les parisiens qui
nous ont fait confiance
en accordant 47,4 toi pas anne hidalgo
36 8% pour nos listes et 13% pour agnès
buzyn cette campagne
[Applaudissements]
cette campagne je les aborder comme
j'aborde la vie avec authenticité avec
enthousiasme avec passion avec le refus
de la fatalité et de toute forme de
déterminisme en jeu les mener dans la
clarté
je les mener dans la constance sans
renier mon histoire ni trahir mes
convictions j'ai mis mon énergie à
convaincre les parisiennes et parisiens
quand tant d'autres me demandait de
convaincre les appareils
j'ai emmené avec moi toute une nouvelle
génération qui avait l'envié et
l'énergie de changer paris j'ai ainsi
rompu avec les haines les rancoeurs les
divisions qui ont affaibli et fait
perdre la droite parisienne depuis 2001
nous sommes allés partout nous sommes
allés voir ce que plus personne ne va
voir
nous sommes allés voir ceux qui ne
votent plus ceux qui ne croient plus en
la politique
ceux qui ont abandonné à force d'être
abandonné ensemble avec tous mes
colistiers nous avons redressé la droite
à paris
nous n'avons pas rendu vie à un parti
nous avons rendu vie à des valeurs nous
n'avons pas rendu vie à une ligne nous
avons rendu vie à une espérance
nous avons pris des engagements avec les
parisiens
nous les tiendrons
je félicite jean pierre lecoq florence
berthou jeanne de serre agnès evren
philippe goujon francis szpiner et
geoffroy boulard qui sont élus maires ce
soir mais je souhaite aussi félicité
avec autant de force tous les policiers
qui ont obtenu de nombreux sièges
d'opposition dans des arrondissements où
la droite avait disparu depuis des
années j'y vois la confirmation que
quand on est dans la proximité
il est possible de regagner la confiance
des citoyens
je remercie profondément tous ces
parisiennes toutes ces parisiennes tous
ces parisiens qui nous ont accordé leur
confiance
le scrutin de ce soir est marqué par une
abstention inédite pour un scrutin manie
municipales à paris
mais ce soir je ne pleurerai pas avec le
choeur des pleureuses
car cette abstention n'est pas la faute
des français elle est de la
responsabilité de ceux qui nous
gouvernent de ceux qui ont gouverné
localement et nationalement
j'irai même plus loin
cette abstention ce soir sont ceux là
même qui se complaisent dans cette
situation qui leur permet si souvent
d'état cite réélection d'année en année
nous nous battons nous battons des
records d'abstention sans qu'aucune
volonté de changement ne s'exprime alors
je vais vous dire cette abstention ne me
décourage pas bien au contraire elle me
conforte dans mon engagement politique
et ma détermination à agir car se
rejettent du vote conduit à ce qu'une
part croissante de français ne s'exprime
plus dans les urnes il s'exprime par les
manifestations
les affrontements les contestations
c'est un cocktail dangereux qui
nécessitent une réaction forte de
l'autorité une défense sans concession
sans faiblesse des valeurs de la
république et de ses principes
si le politique ne fait pas très
rapidement la démonstration de sa
capacité à réduire les fractures
c'est la nation même qui peut être en
danger j'ai toujours été dans l'action
j'ai toujours été dans la proximité
je n'ajouterai pas de l'écoeurement à
l'écoeurement
nous serons pas de ceux qui tournent le
dos à ceux qui nous ont élus mais
candidat élu ce dimanche resteront aux
côtés des parisiens au quotidien dans
tous les arrondissements
le changement était possible à paris la
république en marche a préféré la
victoire d'anne hidalgo dont elle a vu
pourtant critiqué le bilan pendant des
mois
le score de ce soir ne donne pas la
majorité absolue à la maire sortante
nous avions enclencher une dynamique la
dynamique du changement
mais cette stratégie d' échec individuel
d'agnès busan a découragé déstabiliser
et démobilisés de notre très nombreux
électeurs
ce soir je veux dire à tous les
parisiens qui ont voté pour mais liste
ce qu'il représente au conseil de paris
nous n'étions qu'à peine 25 élus au
conseil de paris au début de la campagne
nous serons à l'issue de cette élection
plus de 60
le mois de campagne nous ont permis de
montrer ce que pouvait être la droite
quand elle parle à tous les électeurs à
tous les quartiers à toutes les familles
cette droite là qui sait écouter qui ne
se renie pas qui affirme ses valeurs ses
droites là peut à nouveau incarner une
espérance
c'est ce visage de la droite que nous
continuerons à 1 l'aca blement à porter
avec toute notre énergie et toute notre
détermination
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]